do it
let's do it y'all let's do it
and we
live
once
again
here we go with this y'all hold up a
second see
this is what happens when you do stuff
live man
i uh
are you kidding me
every time i you know what i mean it's
like i had it all set up it's ready to
go and then this happens
like what
there we go
okay
hey it's your favorite podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up y'all we got a big show today
i'm reviewing some shows i saw a day
shift movie with jamie foxx and i saw
the sandman on net both of them are on
netflix so i'm gonna talk about that
loved those oh well you know i don't
know if i love them we're going to talk
about pets having fish tanks
doritos has a new flavor
summer camp
and ezra miller is going crazy but
welcome back
[Music]
yeah i don't know what's going on you
know
you know this is what happens when you
do it live you know what i mean it is
what it is so there's nothing that can
be done you know what let me get my uh
uh what do you call it okay here we go
and then we also you know i have the rap
recap so i got some new beats man from
this
producer called fingers is his name uh i
think it's how it goes i think i'll try
to get i got to make sure i put the
right uh
information up
on his um thing
but you know like i say welcome to
riffin with griffin i am your host eric
griffin uh please make sure you
subscribe
share and uh all that good stuff
you know i don't know why this the the
the animation didn't come up
that's that's kind of weird but anyways
i'm also on twitch
oh it did come out make sure you follow
me on twitch eric griffin gaming i got a
store
if you want to support me you know i got
to fix my patreon like how it look like
what i'm offering and all that kind of
stuff just make it one price we'll
figure all that stuff out i'm still
working on it you know what i mean um
anyways that's all that you know
and
today's
episode just so you know
uh today's episode
now a word from our sponsor
better help
easy and affordable online therapy
get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com slash griffin
that's better
h-e-l-p
dot com
slash griffin for ten percent off
okay what's up everybody uh everybody
that's in the chat live thank you for
being here as usual appreciate your
support and love i want to interact with
you guys today because we got a lot of
subjects and a lot of things to talk
about i appreciate the likes the likes
the shares and all that helps me
help me help you help me so that goes in
there too anybody to you know super
chats and all this stuff is always
appreciated the eric griffin store is
live if you want to you know get some my
little silly merch i'm getting some new
uh getting some new stuff
um
new new art designs to put on different
shirts and stuff but it's just i mean
really when you buy a merch from a comic
it's just you're really just supporting
you know what i mean you're just saying
hey man here's this and thanks for and
i'm giving you a thank you with that so
it's it's just it is what it is
keeps me doing the free content for
y'all i appreciate it um
yeah so here we are man another episode
of riffing with griffin reviewing with
griffin this week but i do have other
stuff that i want to get into and talk
about
on
this week's episode of the podcast and
as you see my background right now is a
fish tank you know what i mean and i
just got me thinking about um
just got me thinking about
pets
do you have pets what's your favorite
pet you know
let's put a pole up what's your favorite
pet
you know what i mean it's like you know
and usually when you think about pet
when you think about pets
um
um
you know it's like it's either dog or
cat
right you know like what's what's your
what's your thing you know it's like you
know you think you think of a pet
dog cats here's my thing
when we talking about pets there's only
two pets like i just said
a dog
and a cat
everything else is nonsense
nonsense
people that got snakes
get out of my face
if you got a little trilantula aquarium
get out of my face
lizards iguanas uh you know people that
got like rats and hamsters and all this
kind of stuff get out of here that's not
a pet
a pet is something that you can let roam
free
and then you know you don't got to worry
about it or it's going to come to you
when you call it it's going to show you
some love if they don't show you love
it's not a pet
you know and i'm not talking about if
you on a farm do you but i'm talking
about urban living you live in a house
you live in an apartment you don't gotta
you know you know what i mean
dogs cats those are pets man you see
somebody with a snake wrapped around
their neck what's wrong with you that's
not a pet
that's a that's a wild ass animal man
i can't stand it and then how about this
the big one is people that got fish
tanks
fish tanks a fish is not a pet a fish
tank is basically a rock bath that's
what it is it's an expensive ass rock
bath i know a friend of mine a couple
they always fussing with a fish tank
always like oh man we just got this new
coral it's like 800
what
so you bought a 800 rock that you keep
it in a bathtub
and you got dirty ass animals that's
swimming around it and [ __ ] on it
and you think that that's a pet that
that's fun that you got to clean up it's
like just take the fish out and just
have some have the rocks out just have
rocks and coral and leaves and a little
you know
little ships and stuff make it that
but to have the fish in there
defecating on everything that you have
to clean it out
and you spend 800 for this rock i i just
i don't
understand it okay
i ain't never gonna have a fish tank
okay
i wanted to get a dog
but i've always wanted a dog and i've
never had a dog i was the only child i
had a single parent
so having a dog was like
i have always understood that a dog
comes with a lot of responsibility
it's the reason why rachel and i don't
have a dog even though
you know we
we actually are fighting about it
anytime i mention rachel i got to do the
rachel graphic rachel
griffin
so
i talk about getting a dog with rachel
you know and she like she'll always look
at the thing and of course of course she
fancy as hell so she's like looking at
that well it's gotta be purebred it's
gotta be this we're not going to the
pound you know i don't want to rescue
you know she's fancy like that all right
that's not even the point though she
just wants the dog when they're cute
when they're puppies you know oh it's a
puppy but she don't want to take care of
it that's why we haven't got a dog
because she's like i'm not picking up
any dog's poop i'm not picking up any
poop while you're out of town
you know i mean then it's just me and
the dog and then like she works you know
she goes to work and then like so what
are we going to do so i recognize the
responsibility of having a dog okay
that's a lot
but i am more partial to dogs
than to cats
but
when you have a good cat
like i like i think the best pet is a
cat that acts like a dog if you know
what i mean by that it's like you go
come here meow meow or whatever your
stupid name you have for your cat and it
comes to you
and then it's very loving and but then
at the same time a cat is like
independent so it'll come give you some
love but when it's done it's like okay
i'm out
and then it's just roaming around at
your place doing whatever it's supposed
to do you got the stupid uh
rug covered thing that the cat is right
you know climbing on and scratching
everything up okay so you got one of
those and then you're good so like a cat
is like hey a cat is like a side piece
you know what i mean that's your side
piece of love because it's just it's not
all the time you know you don't gotta
like a dog
a dog could be like a side piece that
want to be the main
you know what i mean because the dog is
always gonna be like hey hey hey hey hey
give me attention give me attention give
me attention hey what you doing what you
what you're doing are you like hey ma'am
you know just my you know so cat knows
the cat is like come over and be like
wow
and then it just goes away
you know that's a perfect kind of
relationship you want to have with your
pet so i like pets like that my boy
matthew espinoza on my other podcast jen
the gen make sure you check that out too
man jen too jen
he has two cats and they're really i
like them because they'll come over to
me you know they're and then they'll
just like you know get some love and
they're just kind of just there it's
good company so i don't know i think
could we get a cat because another thing
i like about cats is you know if you get
some of that electronic stuff where you
can like water and feed them you don't
have you could leave a cat i think you
can leave a cat in your place for like
two or three days and not worry you
can't do that with a dog you leave your
dog two three days you're gonna come
home and your place is gonna be a wreck
you know what i mean especially
depending on the dog right
so i don't know where y'all are at it
looks like the pole is like 80 dog
uh
you know what i mean so i don't know
uh yeah we have to we have to we have to
i don't know how to just think about it
you know because like
because then you know it's like rachel
showed me a cat that she liked and said
we were having this little thing because
she was like the cat was like fluffy as
hell it looked like a little lion but it
was a cat and it was just like a little
video on tick-tock that she likes to
look at
right and uh but i was like that hair is
to be everywhere and she's like
that's what rachel thinks she goes no
cats rub off all their hair
and then they put it in their mouth and
that's why it's a little cat ball you
know then then they put it someplace
else i'm like are you kidding me like
she's never had a pet you know she's
never had a pet like cats
if you have some kind of fluffy animal
then you've decided you want hair
everywhere that's just right
you tell me people that have
if you have a pet
and is it is it at what point do you
just have to go you have to just give up
and go okay
put all your stuff you know everything i
have owned is gonna be have cat dander
and cat hair and dog hair
all over it you know so i don't know
it's like i feel like if i had a cat
right now the cat would be chilling like
it might just jump up on my you know
jump up right here and just kind of be
like
and then like you know warm around then
it's gone i could just be like shoo you
know and then it's gone so i don't know
cats over dogs dogs over cats but here's
what i'm saying
nothing else
okay let me reiterate a snake is not a
pet
if you have to feed your wild-ass animal
another wild-ass animal
i'm out
okay
right imagine if you had a tiger and you
had defeated a little poodle
you know what i mean
that's what it is having a snake
when you have a snake you gotta feed it
a live rat a mouse
no
thank you
if the if this snake wants to eat
a live
animal
you're next that's just how i feel about
it you're gonna wake up and the snake
gonna be like halfway up your body
trying to digest you
i'm out
okay
so
that's it that's how we started the
podcast that's all i have to say
about
that
all right guys let's get into some stuff
now um
i guess i won't get into the previews
yet i'll do the reviews of the shows and
stuff last i guess
uh here's a in in fat news
if that's a should that be a thing
should i call it fat news in fat news
doritos has new flavors
right so they got a ketchup and mustard
flavor yuck
yuck
um
doritos are already like two i mean are
you a doritos fan like i like doritos
when it's like the little tiny
um
it's like the little tiny bags then you
have like you know where you only got
like 16 of them in there you know then
you just like
you know you're just like okay you're
done with the bag and you know those
little variety packs my problem before
when i was younger i'd be like oh you
know well
you well you know how you eat like one
variety pack then you go you eat one
then you go ooh that wasn't even a lot
so let me just have another the next
thing you know you six bags in so just
get a big gigantic bag of uh doritos but
no i i don't i'm not a huge doritos fan
okay not cute i mean i like i say i like
them in small doses but damn these
flavors man but i'm understanding it
from reading about this stuff because
oreos does this too they come out with
ridiculous flavors
as a marketing ploy to make you want to
buy the original and it's like a market
study that it looks like so when doritos
comes out with this nonsense flavors you
go to the store and then you go
mustard
mustard doritos and you go i don't want
that nonsense and then you go get some
cool ranch you know
what is the original doritos flavor is
it like i don't even know what the
original doritos flavor is because i
always think of cool ranch and then that
other one
um
not sure
who knows all right we're gonna end that
okay boom
um
dogs one so yeah i don't i don't know
i don't know why they do this but i
think i think it's like like i said some
marketing ploy so they come out with
some weird flavor
you know it'll be like you know peanut
butter mint chocolate dorito i mean um
uh that sounds nasty uh oreos and then
you'll be like
then you go to the store you see that
and you go let me just get the originals
and then you get them rachel caught
herself buying some thin dorito
i keep saying doritos thin oreos she
bought the thin oreos um
[Music]
a couple weeks ago
and it's just like here's my problem
with those kind of things you get some
thin oreos right
and this is what happens it's just like
what i said about the little bag of
doritos
it's cool
if you grab one bag of doritos and you
eat it as a little cheat and then you're
done move away this is what happens when
you get the little thin oreos you and
your mind go oh these are the thin oreos
so i can eat like
more than three of these you know but
it's all the same
and it's like the thin noise it's like
real thin cookie in a real thin uh layer
of the the cream
don't get me started on some oreos man
and you know fat news i will tear
a bag of oreos
so i don't know what you guys think
about
that but apparently ketchup chips are in
canada yeah
that's what i heard too
which is i don't understand like why
canada
is more catchy than the united states if
i was a terrorist you know and i hate to
even put this out
but like if you wanted to really
get the united states
i would go to the catch-up factory and
that's where i'd put the poison
because
what kind of security they got at the
catch-up factory you know
and then that would be the thing that
would get everybody because all the
ketchup would go out to all the
mcdonald's the ketchup would go out to
all the fat you know fat places or if
you're a conspiracy theorist and you're
trying to if you're trying to end
obesity and you're trying to do it in a
terrible way you know that that would be
the movie conspiracy where you would
like put the you know
you put the the stuff in ketchup and the
next thing you know
you know all the fat people just start
dropping dropping like flies man they
start dropping like flies
anyways give me your uh thoughts on uh
doritos guys in the comments what's your
favorite dorito flavor y'all what is
your favorite dorito flavor let me know
um like i say i think i i think i'm
partial to cool ranch but it's all salty
and nasty but i think i could i could
tear up the original flavor too i think
maybe it's like original or cool ranch a
very small bag i will tear that up and
then we out we out all right y'all
that's uh my uh
fun little doritos rant you know i'm
doing different things on the show
now i want to talk about one of my
guilty pleasures um
you know this is something we have to
get into because it's going it's going
on right now all right and that is big
brother i just want oh that's not big
brother where where's the big brother
where is it
oh here it is no that's not it
why well that's my website too eric
griffin.com which i still haven't
updated so if you want to help me with
that still
i know i say that all the time and then
i never get anybody to actually help me
you know because it's a lot you know
what i mean
anyways though let's go let's do a quick
big brother update right now
quick big brother update so it happened
again y'all
i love big brother and i've talked about
it if you don't if you're not a big
brother fan whatever okay so i want to
just talk about this last episode i
watched a big brother it was
the endurance challenge that they always
do every single year
it's a wall
and the people are holding they're
standing on a little they're on a wall
and they're standing on a little ledge
very little ledge and there's two
like sort of things they have to hold on
to on the side of their body they have
to hold on to this wall right and the
wall is moving forward and moving back
and then water and goo and all kinds of
stuff are being sprayed on them and it's
an endurance challenge whoever can hold
on to the wall the longest
whoever's the last person wins head of
household right
i'm looking at this and i'm sitting here
with rachel and i go see and i've talked
to you guys about this before this whole
inclusion nonsense that they like to do
but then they set the people up for
failure this is one of those
competitions though that i think is
geared towards where it helps everybody
in a way it's a very because the same
kind of people win this competition all
the time
whoever let me tell you who wins this
all the time it's usually a very slender
athletic woman who can win this because
her body weight isn't so heavy that when
they're leaning forward she can't hold
herself up
and she's strong enough to stay there
and then the weight balance it balances
out great so it's usually a woman who
wins this or a very slender dude who
wins this
and these are the people this is how it
works too here's how it goes out and i
called it i was like okay first three
people that's gonna go out of this the
two big girls and the old guy
that's and that's exactly what happened
the first person off the wall every
single time is the fattest girl in the
house
bye
she falls first
i knew it and i just go see this is what
i'm talking about right
like why set her up like this give give
better competitions for people like this
so they can win if you're gonna have her
on the show
if you're gonna have a heavyset person
male or female on the show
then you gotta have competitions that
help them too
they never win
period
i me you tell me
somebody in the comments correct me if
i'm wrong has a fat person ever won big
brother please put that in the comments
i just need to see
all right anyways so i could be like oh
good so i could have something to root
for anyway
big girl number one false
big girl number two
false
old guy who was also heavy set
falls
every single time
and then what happens is in the middle
you see like these people who are like
sort of in shape but not really in shape
they always fall and then in the end
the big strong muscle dudes they can't
stay up there either because their their
body weight is so heavy and their arms
and you know they just can't do it and
then they fall and sure enough i called
it i was like it's going to be the black
girl she's skinny athletic or it's going
to be this slender dude but he didn't
want to win because of whatever so he
fell off
everybody
it happened and it happens exactly the
same way
every single year okay
every single year it happens so
a fat person has one american idol
somebody said
that's different like imagine if
american idol
part of the singing competition you had
to run an endurance race and then sing
that would be terrible that would be so
messed up ruben stutter would have been
like what
what why i gotta i gotta run and then
sing so that would be stupid i don't
know you know let's just let's little
nothing
he's always on the gaming channel
we don't know what he really looks like
even if it's a guy or a girl we don't
even know
anyways um
all right y'all
um again thanks for being here but let
us
let us now
get a word
from our sponsor
i have to say it right now a word from
our sponsor better help y'all
listen
i am a huge advocate of
therapy i am currently in therapy and i
really love the process all right if you
think about it like this
we do things to take care of our bodies
we do we we have to sleep better for our
body that's what also helps your mind we
have to eat right and we have to do some
movement some sort of exercise these are
things we do to take care of our bodies
i think your mind works the same way and
i think the way to do that is therapy
look therapy's not going to solve your
problems but it's going to help you
organize your thoughts and recognize
patterns with an expert who can maneuver
through that these people study this and
they know how things start and finish
and they've seen this before and they're
able to help you like go huh i never
thought of that before and i love that
moment when i have that in therapy i
love it
so that's why i suggest therapy for
everybody here guys better help us
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live chat only therapy sessions
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy
you get matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours there are plenty of ways
to support healthy brain like learning a
new language or taking power naps
and there's also better help online
therapy
our listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com griffin that's
better
h-e-l-p-com slash griffin
all right y'all
yeah we're going you know we're going
smooth today
uh you know smooth action here on
riffin with griffin
um let's see who else i wanted to talk
about today oh you know what i wanted to
talk about this today too summer camp
you know
well you know it's summertime and i i
just found this thing it's probably for
some real summer camp thing but summer
camp are y'all still going to summer
camp do you remember going to summer
camp are you sending your kids to summer
camp what do you feel about summer camp
and i started to think like what were
like did i i went to summer camp i don't
even remember i was in the boy scouts
for like a second like a hot second but
i joined this troupe that i didn't
realize it was all about
backpacking
and like carrying all your water and
food you know six miles into the
whatever
and then you know setting up camp and
doing all that i didn't last
i just remember as a kid being like i
don't like this
i like when i when i camp and when i
camp i want to pull up
you see the campground it's nice
you see your car still
you know you have all the amenities but
you can always just jump in the car and
go home if you need to
it's nice there's like a nice bathroom
someplace close by you get in the
outdoors but at the same time you know
you're not feeling like
you're not feeling like it's medieval
times and you have to go hunt for your
own food you know what i mean you got to
go you know you we had to go like get
water from a stream and then boil it now
that kind of stuff and i was like what
am i doing this is
what
it's like if i had if i didn't have my
clothes on it'd be naked and afraid you
know what i mean so
i don't know
i don't know how y'all feel about summer
camp but it's like i think now
everybody's a little nervous i think
that's like a feeling of like i don't
know if i want to send it's like you
know it's like you know we used to be
you trusted things you know you sent
your kids to summer camp and you just
like thought oh they're having a good
time and i get a little break for like a
week right but now people are just so
nervous about everything when you look
at the internet and you just look up you
just google like bad things that happen
at summer camp and then boom you know
it's like this summer camp got closed
down this one got closed down whatever
the thing is and you're just kind of
like nervous but
i'm just trying to think of some fun
things that i used to do in the summer
and i just you know it's weird that i
just felt like
for me my summers were always full of
playing basketball
that's the things i remember the most i
don't remember going to summer camp you
know i think my mom wanted us she would
like take me traveling or something like
that
uh
but i don't remember necessarily
and then when i was in high school i
just remember my summer was always about
playing basketball it was just about you
know i was into sports into that it was
like getting ready for the season you
know having the summer league you know
and then only once i remember that i had
to go to summer school because my grades
were bad but like what what are the
things that you look forward to in
summer so much as it's like you know a
day off i guess i've been i haven't been
a kid
sorry for so long that i don't even know
or like i don't have like a normal
pattern you know it's like weekends
don't mean anything to me in terms of
like you know i haven't had a real job
in a long time my job is like you're on
a set or you're traveling or you're
doing podcasts now so it's like you know
what's the time off is the time i have
to set for myself but like regular folk
you know it's like monday through friday
then you have the weekend off so people
look forward to the weekend so it's like
what do you do for the weekend and then
it's like if you have kids like summer
is really centered around when you have
children because it's like okay they're
off school now what do i do with these
little mothers you know what i mean
these little mfa's you know they just
out here you know terrorizing now you
have to like oh man because some people
still have to go to work and then what
are you doing with your kid you know
what i mean so it's like what did you
look forward to when you were when you
were a kid uh you know because i'm also
from an era of like going outside and
playing games and stuff like i used to
in my neighborhood we played hide and go
seek we played freeze tag we played
baseball even though i wasn't even into
baseball but we just played baseball in
our
in you know in a front yard you know you
know what i mean on the street we would
play baseball
and um
with tennis balls you know we were just
like so the tennis balls would fly it
wouldn't break any windows and stuff but
that's how we did it you know we played
tackle football on the front yard grass
like crazy tac like playing tackle
football uh you know it's like that so i
just look forward to those kind of
things just having like where you you
stayed in late and you like went i mean
i think from when i was a kid it was
just more of a routine you know it was
like you went to school monday through
friday saturday morning you woke up and
watched cartoons and kung fu theater and
then you just you know that was your
life you know what i mean
it was like it was more
even my tv schedule when i was a kid was
more like it was like i knew what shows
came on on what night because you had to
watch them on these nights so it was
like watching wrestling waiting for
saturday so it was like saturday morning
cartoons wwf and kung fu theater that
was every saturday
and then it was like you go out and play
right
and then the summer like what do you
like so this summer it's it's felt like
more the same because i was an only
child i guess my parent my mom sent me
like i would visit relatives in central
america i'd go to belize
i would do that a few times you know but
it was like i didn't really
i don't know i don't i don't i don't
remember anything memorable in my
summers you know until like you know
until i really was in high school and i
was you know doing summer doing summer
league basketball so
what's your camp experience i would love
to hear if you had a good camp
experience or a bad camp experience oh i
remember this
i remember what i did one summer
actually it was called the national
parks caravan
i was my mom signed me up at the beverly
hills ymca so i used to be on the swim
team at the beverly hills ymca that's
actually the first time i experienced
real racism too like where it was like
in your face and you knew like you knew
someone was doing this because you
weren't white like someone was like and
i even as a kid i remember thinking to
myself oh it's happening right now
you know i was like oh this guy's being
racist towards me and i was like oh
that's interesting that's i just
remember as a kid thinking of it like
that as if it was some sort of social
experiment you know but even back then i
thought to myself
you know
i'm still here
you know what i mean like
i don't know it was just weird but
anyway i was on the beverly hills swim
team and then i went on this uh
national parks caravan so it was me and
like five or six other kids we were very
young and we were in a van with these
two adults and we would just drive to
all the national parks we just drove but
i'll never forget like on the way back
the it was this tall black dude and this
chubby white lady they were the the the
the camp counselors or whatever right
and they got into a big ass fight
all right like right in front of us like
on the way home they just got into a
fight you know and he would the dude was
cursing her out you know what i mean
he was like using all kind of ex
expletives and just telling her off and
i was like damn what is going on you
know and you're just like a little kid
seeing them but now as an adult i look
back i think they was having sex
through the whole trip
they look like that kind of couple i
think and i think they just had like a
lover's fight and it wasn't until later
that i thought oh i wonder if that's
what was going on but i do remember that
being a good time we went to the grand
canyon we went to yellowstone we went to
like all these different places and it's
like you know
i don't remember much other than like i
remember fighting with a kid in a movie
theater you know we were in a movie
theater and this kid was like you know
like he we were fighting with each other
he elbowed me in the face and i punched
him and it was like so we had a fight in
a movie theater
they had a fight you know just this this
this like couple had a fight and then i
just remember the name of the thing
going on a national parks uh caravan
so
i don't know
i don't know later yeah did anybody go
to band camp like what was your camp
experience so if you had like a really
good camp experience i'd love to see
that in the comments and i'll respond to
you so summer camp summer
what's fun in the summer
all right guys um in some darker news um
you know
let me wait let me turn make sure this
is on and some darker news man
let's talk about this dude
so apparently
this dude
this dude ezra miller is like
off the rails man
so you know he's flash he's been in a
bunch of things i guess
but he's flash in uh
the dc universe and they made a movie
and it's like on hold right now i guess
so ezra miller accused of harassing
women in germany and iceland choking
victim breaks or silence
so
i don't know if you saw the video
but he's like outside you know and this
lady's like sort of like messing around
with him like hey you know whatever and
then he's like oh you wanna fight you
know and he like grabs her and chokes
her out like you know he grabs her and
like pulls her down chokes and his
friends are filming and then they start
to go whoa dude you know what i mean and
then the filming stops you know i don't
know why they released that uh that just
seems kind of like yeah there's the
there's the video right there you know
let's see if i could i'm not gonna plant
these oh
oh they're not oh i can't show it it
doesn't show it but anyways
it uh it was crazy you know he
now here's the thing
you know sometimes when like right now
i wonder
if people that are like you know they
they're they're putting out stuff like
this on the internet
like you know do people really care
about this guy
you know or do people really care about
like what's
like do you care about violence against
women is that why you're doing this and
it's like sometimes i wonder like the
way people put out these stories i
wonder to myself
is are you just putting out this story
because you want to cancel this guy
shame this guy get some
get some you know click bait about this
guy or you do you really care about
violence against women because i feel
like the stories would be written in a
way that's gonna help us be like all
right this is what's happening these are
the numbers here's what we could do to
combat this here's what we could do to
you know make sure this doesn't happen
again you know more stories about
respecting women i think it's like there
should be more stories about women you
know here's a woman doing this here's a
woman doing that here's a woman doing
that you know so we can like also see
them in a light that is like a better
light than just always being a victim
you know what i mean like that's what
they always show so it's like i don't
know if this is very helpful at all but
at the same time i also think it's like
look
any kind of violence against anybody is
terrible but this guy needs some serious
help you know this guy's like obviously
an alcoholic you know he's he's been in
so many fights so many altercations so
many things about him it's like at this
point it's like yo man
it's either like we got to get him out
of the public eye so he can go work on
himself uh
like i don't know
so it's like it's like it's like all
this stuff that's coming out about him
and it's so sensationalized that i don't
even know what to believe you know what
i mean because people say a lot of
nonsense about you and it's like you
know you know he obviously needs some
help is what i'm saying and should that
also be something that we talk about
when they're putting this stuff out is
it just to put this out and just be like
here he is he did this and it's like you
clickbait to be like ooh let's see what
this guy did i mean is there any
compassion for like uh
someone to be like hey he also has
mental issues and because of his mental
issues and stuff he's going out here and
hurting people and it looks like it's
mostly women so it's like let's like
you know hey man
who who's in his camp i mean it's just
like he just seems to be a cash cow that
like managers and agents and movie
companies are like well people like to
see this guy so let's like see how we
can exploit him but at the same time the
cancer culture is like yo we got to get
rid of this guy so it's like is there
any help at all in this process
is there any like moving forward to
actually help society in this process i
don't know that's just how i feel about
it i don't know so
you know and by the way it's like it's
like
it's a shame too because these victims
of his
outbursts and and
mental stuff you know what i mean the
victims of you know
doing his thing it's like they're just
used as puppets now as opposed to like
you know
what like is it now is it about them
suing him for money or like you know
what i mean like it's like
where is
the compassion for everybody involved in
the situation so we can make this better
and use it as a cautionary tale for
other people not to to do this it's like
people that have substance abuse issues
it's an addiction people that are
suffering from addiction
the the consequences of the things that
they do and when they're suffering from
this addiction sucks
you know they hurt a lot of people
and it's like then if then all we do is
fixate on those actions
and then not ever talk about well what
can we do to help
people with addiction and help other
people to not get addicted help people
and it's like you know if i let me say
it again you know a word from our
sponsor better help man you know therapy
is a you know a good help for this you
know what i mean so
i don't know
so now this i guess not even like the
lighter side of it but like
what do
what should dc do
is the question
what should dc do
there's three options i guess
it's
you just scrap the movie all together
you send out a message
that you go
we don't want to tolerate this sort of
behavior
not just
the main one violence against women we
don't want to tolerate that we also
don't want to tolerate this type of
behavior from our you know you've
embarra you're embarrassing
our movie company you're embarrassing
our
the the dc you're embarrassing yourself
and we just don't want to be in business
with someone that does that
is that like the message you want to
send
or is it
so you just scrap the whole thing take
cut your losses whatever it is
or
do you like go hey
we're supporting him he has an addiction
and a problem and we're getting him help
and then you hold the movie back and
then once you do a pr campaign of like
he's out of therapy he's you know
apologized he's giving money to the
victims or whatever they think is you
know the proper thing to do to for
optics take and then they release the
movie and we forget all about it you
know
i don't know
what do you guys think
you know should they just
scrap this all together should they try
to put it out and what message does it
send you know it reminds me of what's
going on in the nfl with this deshaun
watson thing whether you believe the
dude or not
whatever whether you believe the dude or
not
the optics of the whole situation looks
bad
you know because just real brief the the
houston texans set up his contract
knowing that he might get suspended for
a year
so
he's only making sixty thousand dollars
a game this year
once that information is released to the
public that's a slap in the face to the
victims
or anybody that thinks about
violence against women or harassment and
that kind of stuff when you see that you
go that's bad optics you know it's like
that now it seems as if he's getting no
punishment at all that he gets to rest
and and he gets he loses 60 000 and he
gets to keep you know 200 and you know
25
million of his guaranteed contract so
again and again so bringing it back to
this like what's the optics of it that
you think is important i don't have a
lot of female viewers and you know i
wish i wish i did so i'd love to hear
from you females
what do you think about this
what you what should they do in this
situation you know what should they do i
see a lot of people saying you know
should i put up is that the next poll i
need to put up about this
i will um let's let's put up let's put
up another poll about this
um
flash movie
scrap it
or postpone it
i guess those are the two not two
options huh
so what do you guys think of that so you
know i don't know man
it's a it's a very like uh touchy it's a
very touchy subject huh you know you
know what i mean very touchy
you know it's like how you talk about it
people are like you know
you don't care about women you know
whatever it is like that it's like
that's not the case at all it's just
that i think that there's i think
there's more to this there's so much
more to this that we should discuss
that's going on in society that you know
we we want to help
anyway that's how i feel about it
um all right so we talked about summer
camp we got the ezra stuff let's get
into
with as minimal spoilers as possible
that i can i want to talk about these
two
these two shows and then we'll end the
podcast on that these two these two
things that i saw so the first one is
this show you can't really see it but
it's called the sandman
and it's on
the same man it's on netflix uh it's
starring
tom sturridge
boyd holbrook and patton oswalt
uh is doing a voiceover of the of a bird
um it's a fantasy drama upon escaping
after upon escaping after decades of
imprisonment by a mortal
wizard dream the personification of
dreams set about sets about to reclaim
his lost equipment and that's like a
loose thing about what the show's about
um
you know it's a very weird show man i
just want to tell you that but i am a
huge
i'm a huge sci-fi
uh
magic fantasy type person you know what
i mean i'm huge into that ooh i can't
play too much of this trailer because
they're gonna ding me for it it's really
stupid
you know so
i don't know um i i thought
i i love escaping my own reality so when
i watch a show like this i love what
it's all about so i'm gonna tell you all
the things i really liked about this
show it is a drama it is dark it is um i
believe it's it's rated r because
there's violence and gore and sex and
and they talk and it's really like
you know dark subjects and i love that
my thing live i've said before is like
just make shows for adults you know just
just make adult shows and then make kids
shows but don't have this in between you
know so if you're gonna have a show
that's about violence and you think that
it's okay
like if you think it's okay to just to
show to kids all this violence but as
long as there's no blood or gore that
it's okay
i i think that you're doing a disservice
to the story so i'm saying just make a
kids movie
you know
or
make an adult i i would have i would
love them to remake all the avengers
movies and it's rated r
you know what i mean like that uh like
uh um
like the wolverine you know like the
last wolverine logan like logan when you
saw those claws finally
enter someone's body and cut off arms
and stuff it was like oh [ __ ] you know i
want that because i'm an adult if i have
kids and i want to
i'm going to separate you know what i
mean i'll have my own time to watch that
stuff but i think that it should be
adult and anyway my point is i like this
show because of that it's very artsy
fartsy though
and my only complaint about this show is
pick a lane you know are you going to be
a sexy fantasy
driven
drama are you going to be some artsy
fartsy art piece
that's trying to you know it it it kind
of like
it didn't blend enough like there was
one very fascinating episode of like
okay so this guy got a he's he's dream
he's like dream personified so he's like
he's like a wizard he controls the dream
world
and so when people are asleep that's his
word domain you know what i mean and he
gets captured by some mortals because
the guy wants
uh immortality so he thinks he's
capturing the devil but he captures
dream and dream has these three dev he
has his sand that's why they call him
the sandman and that's like how he like
it's one of the sources of his power
and he has this helmet and he has this
uh emerald you know and he had infused
some of his own power in this emerald
and it could grant wishes so the guy
stole that from him and they have him
imprisoned okay and they imprisoned him
for a hundred years so his family had
him imprisoned for a hundred years you
know what i mean
so the um
you know so then so then
there's like some side story where
um
like let me look at the cast
because there's like a i want to get
this guy's name right what is this guy's
name um
oh man he was in wonder woman oh he's
like a great british actor he was in
harry potter
i forgot his name is it david no no no
no wait where oh
wait where's the star oh here the stars
[Laughter]
wait let me show you guys what i'm
looking at
if you guys listen you got to watch live
sometimes and again thanks for being
here thanks for being with me thanks for
sticking with me for like all this time
episode 198 you know we're still we're
getting to
we're getting to um
you know we're going to get to 200 i'm
still trying to figure out what i want
to do live
is his name oh this is this is the guy
yeah yeah yeah yeah david
yeah that's his name
david thulas
great actor man he's such a great actor
but david thula so he's like
his mother
you know his his mother stole the stuff
to escape you know she was pregnant with
him then like you know and i'm not gonna
tell you everything but he ends up with
this gem
and there's and there's this whole
episode where
he he's kind of a psychopath and he
wants the world to stop lying so so
there's this whole episode at a diner
where he's meeting all these people in
the diner and he's using this magic
power to make everyone be honest okay
and what happens at the diner is
mind blogging so i will say
it starts a little slow
because they have to build up about what
this whole thing is about
and there's a there's like three or four
different stories going on within this
story but i think they established the
world they established the characters
they established what everything was
gonna be about and then
uh
i think this i'm gonna wait for the
second season to see if it hits a home
run
because you got the devil in it and hell
and i love all that stuff i love the
mythological stuff so i'm more partial
to that kind of stuff but if you did if
you watched this show and you didn't
like it i totally understand actually
i totally get it it may not be for you
if you're not into like you know and
then there's a lot of like you know
you know uh androgynous behavior and and
that kind of stuff so i don't know
i i i give it i gave it probably a solid
maybe two or three woo-woos
[Music]
whoa so
yeah you have to watch i but but here's
what i'm saying though is like i said
give it a shot if you have netflix it's
free so you can just go watch it you
don't have to you know what i mean just
watch it i'm telling you you got to get
to the end of the first season
um
but get through that middle part because
the middle part really is
i don't know
i mean i i can't give it a strong
recommendation but i strongly will
suggest watching it you know just to
experience some of the things i'm
talking about though so i do you know
like i say i i i recommend it and all
these people that were in the movie it's
really fast oh especially this guy right
here man
oh this guy plays a really great
character so so that guy right there uh
he plays like so dream the the main guy
you know he has good dreams and he also
creates nightmares so the manifestation
of these nightmares are like you know a
being and then like they escaped because
he's been lost for a hundred years so
this nightmare is like you know roaming
around
the earth as uh
as a person and he's a terror he's
terrible person so he's one of the
villains in this thing but he does a
great job and then it gets really dark
there's this sort of serial killer
section that like it's so disturbing and
dark and i was like oh good for them for
even going there with it so it's very
adult it's a very adult show and like i
say i i give it some woo-woos to watch
okay
lastly we got
another a movie that was on netflix
uh and it is starring jamie foxx and
it's called the day shift um
the day shift it stars jamie foxx dave
franco and natasha louis border diesel
man i'm terrible with names it's just
like get it's like damn she's foreign
ass names
but she's great you've seen her she's
been i've seen her in a bunch of other
things uh
all right
if you know me
i love
anything vampire okay that's my [ __ ]
that's my guilty pleasure no matter what
it is i love vampire stuff
so you combine vampire with anything
gory and adult
sexy and violent i'm in
this has got this
and it stars
jamie foxx and snoop dogg
snoop dogg is also in this and he does a
it's like when you see snoop dogg in a
movie it's just snoop dogg in a movie
you know what i'm saying
and so you just kind of go good for you
snoop you know it's like he's like i
don't know snoop has become like like
our favorite uncle that smokes weed and
rap still you know what i'm saying
[Laughter]
probably how you think of me at the end
at the end of the podcast just some like
i just don't do it as well you know but
it's like i love so i also want to tell
you just
i'm biased about it i love this movie i
think it's just a fun campy
movie it's not the best story i'm not
gonna sit here and tell you that it's
like some great powerful story but it's
just fun and jamie foxx is just he's
he's he's fun to root for man
jamie foxx is just fun to root for so
i'm gonna read you the description of
the movie it's like a hard-working
blue-collar dad who just wants to
provide a good life for his quick-witted
eight-year-old daughter
his mundane san fernando valley pool
clean job is a front for his real source
of income hunting and killing vampires
the show opens up with a great vampire
fight
the special effects are dope
i love when like you have a vision of
what you want say a superhero thing to
do that's why the first spider-man with
tony mcgregor was so great because it
was like yes thank you finally this is
spider-man on screen and we get to see
spider-man doing spider-man stuff from
the comic books it's great special
effects are great when it's seamless and
flawless and so this is one of those
moments where you see a vampire doing
some like real cool vampire [ __ ] and i
love it i love it love it love it so
there's this great fight with this old
lady who's a vampire you know and it's
all about them having to like you know
so you know you you tear the teeth out
of the vampires and you sell the so the
teeth are
or what is on the open market how you
make money and there's like this you
know underground sort of like fbi type
place that you know is like a vampire
you know and of course there's a bad
vampire that's trying to run the city
and blah blah blah it's all those kind
of like cheesy corny stuff but i like
how they do it and i also like the music
i like the music it's like this sort of
90s rap is going on in the background at
all times you know and like i say jamie
foxx he he has a way about himself that
he knows how to like
he is he knows how to be like the bad
father
he's a he's a he's like a good dad he
loves his daughter but he's late to pick
her up from school you know it's that
kind of dad you know what i'm saying and
he's also a badass vampire hunter and
and also
shout out again to dave franco dave
franco is just funny man he knows how to
be
a sort of like
he could be good looking dude you know
but he just knows how to play this sort
of like nerdy
guy who pees his pants because he's
scared type of like character so he does
a great job in it too i i'm telling you
i think it's worth the watch it's free
i wouldn't have ever gone to see this in
a movie theater and pay money to see
this movie but i think that if you're
just sitting at home you want to watch
some good adult uh fun
comedy adult
gory movie i give this a movie like four
woo-woos
[Music]
i think that was more than four woo-woos
but i really enjoyed it guys all right
man we uh you know we coming to the end
here man and as you know
when we finish the podcast i want to
shout out to uh let me wait i got to get
the dudes i want to get the dudes uh
name correctly who uh
that's gonna provide today's beats
is um
what's the dude's name
uh
oh wait wait wait wait
it's think well it goes by fingers
oops sorry i think that's his name
i hope he's watching you know
he's gonna he's gonna tell me
wait okay and then you know we i've been
getting good beats from fishy and and my
guy chris you but this guy also sent
some beats and i want to i want to give
him some a shout out where is it how
come i can you know i cannot i never
find the stuff that i want you know what
i mean it's like you get you get
everything prepared and then you come on
here and then and the sucker is isn't
where you want to find it anyway i'll
probably just put it in the description
and tell you guys about it but you know
guys you know how we do it at the end of
the show
with this fingers
yeah yeah
it's the right recap
oh oh
do it again
[Music]
everybody should tell that friend summer
camp
go again
[Music]
i'm a fan like stan
eric griffin is the man
who is there
that fool is a killer he's
still in the flag
[Music]
uh
[Music]
make you want to move your feet in your
seat
this is a treat so we can't rap
it 50 years old
it's gone
thanks for watching again
everybody tell your friends
[Music]
we're at recap
see you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]